A developer just killed the Claude code token problem for free.
Now, your $20 plan is just as powerful as the $100 plan. Here's how.
The problem is this, every time you start a new Claude code session,
it re reads your entire code base, every file, every function,
thousands of tokens gone before you even ask a question.
This is why you're burning through tokens and wasting your money.
But this tool, graphify, fixes it. First, run this new tool,
then watch as it reads your entire code base. What happens is it builds a full
knowledge graph of everything inside every connection, every relationship. Now,
during your next session, Claude won't reread all those files.
It simply navigates the new graph, saving you a ridiculous amount of tokens.
Comment, graphify for my complete setup guide.